Chaque année, les oiseaux migrateurs
faire leur voyage épique à travers l'Europe.
Sud en automne,
nord au début du printemps.
Ils ont volé ici
Pour des milliers d'années,
mais récemment,
il y en a eu moins dans nos cieux.
Certaines espèces ont même complètement disparu.
Pourquoi?
Mon nom est Christian.
Depuis plus de 20 ans,
J'ai observé et étudié les oiseaux.
J'ai appris à piloter un ULM
pour voler à leurs côtés.
j'ai partagé
cette expérience magique
avec tous ceux qui souhaitent voir ces merveilles.
Mais je ne peux pas supporter de rester là
et regarder ces oiseaux disparaître.
Qu'est-ce qui pourrait les décourager
de survoler nos terres ?
Les villes en expansion ?
La prairie en voie de disparition ?
Y a-t-il d'autres raisons ?
Je veux comprendre et agir.
Je veux faire tout ce que je peux
pour aider ces oiseaux à continuer
leurs pèlerinages saisonniers.
Alors j'ai rêvé
un projet un peu fou,
une école de la migration.
je vais m'envoler
avec un petit groupe d'oies,
découvrir avec eux les pièges
et les dangers de notre monde moderne
et trouver une nouvelle façon de traverser nos terres.
Alors je les laisserai à leur liberté
avec l'espoir que mes élèves
retiendront les leçons de leur voyage
et un jour
les transmettre à d'autres oies sauvages.
Viens avec moi.
Laisse moi te montrer
les routes secrètes des oiseaux migrateurs.
Nous y voilà,
Je vole avec mes oiseaux.
C'est le mois d'août et c'est le moment
J'ai choisi de commencer notre grand voyage.
Nous quittons les plaines d'Alsace,
empruntant la route aux cigognes.
Puis au-dessus des forêts
des Vosges à l'Auvergne.
De la Loire jusqu'au bout
aux marais de la côte atlantique,
le paradis des oiseaux migrateurs.
Oh pardon,
J'ai oublié de vous présenter.
Voici mes huit jeunes oies.
Toutes sont des oies grises,
la race la plus commune dans ces terres.
Les cinq aux becs jaunes
sont de la famille scandinave
et les trois soeurs au bec rose,
du côté sibérien.
Alors me voilà,
le chef de cette petite famille
d'oies sauvages.
Tous nés ce printemps,
mais dans des couveuses chez moi.
Alors, comment suis-je devenu le père adoptif?
D'abord,
Je suis resté avec les œufs jour et nuit,
leur parler
jusqu'à leur éclosion.
C'est ma voix, avec mon visage,
que les oisons reconnaissent.
Salut bébé.
C'est moi il y a 20 ans
apprendre à le faire.
Les oies s'identifient à qui les accompagne
dans les premières heures de leur vie,
même si c'est un homme.
Au cours des prochaines semaines,
Je renforcerais ce lien.
La même méthode
a travaillé pour mes oies aujourd'hui.
S'ils semblent à l'aise avec l'ULM,
c'est parce que je leur ai appris à se dandiner,
voleter puis voler à côté.
C'est pourquoi ils n'ont aucun problème
me suit aujourd'hui.
Les oies grises migrent du nord de l'Europe
au sud de l'Espagne pour passer l'hiver.
Dans la nature,
ils apprennent l'itinéraire de cette migration
en suivant leurs parents
en descendant.
Sur le chemin du retour,
ils le gèrent souvent eux-mêmes.
Voler dans la lumière croustillante du matin,
le paysage apparaît clairement.
Châteaux, clochers, villages, rivières.
De nombreux repères pour mes élèves navigateurs
qui calent le parcours dans leur mémoire
avec la vue
c'est huit fois plus net que le mien.
Ils calculent leur position
en utilisant les étoiles et le soleil,
et possèdent des cellules capables de détecter
le champ magnétique terrestre,
une boussole intégrée dans leur œil
et un GPS dans leur bec.
Ils sont parfaitement équipés
et pourtant c'est moi qu'ils suivent.
Il fait chaud, becs ouverts,
leurs langues
attraper la moindre goutte d'humidité.
Tant de signes clairs qu'ils ont soif.
Sous nous,
une gravière à l'étrange eau turquoise.
Par instinct,
une oie grise sauvage ne se poserait pas ici.
C'est l'heure du premier cours.
Drôle d'endroit pour nager.
En effet, mes oies n'aiment pas plonger
dans cette eau des Caraïbes.
Ici, rien n'est sauvage.
Pourtant, c'est un endroit sûr.
En surmontant leur méfiance,
mes oies en ont une de plus
lieu de repos sur leur route.
Prendre l'avantage
de ce que l'homme a fait à la nature.
C'est la morale de cet après-midi.
Nous volons depuis le matin,
la faim s'installe.
Ils ne sont toujours pas habitués
aux longs vols.
Dans la nature, ils se régalent de pousses tendres
d'herbe tendre et de graines.
Mais ici, pas de prés,
terres agricoles juste cultivées
à perte de vue.
C'est la même histoire ailleurs,
rien à picorer.
Je décide de m'installer près d'un champ de maïs.
Leçon numéro deux,
profitant de la récolte.
Graines, feuilles, maïs.
Un festin gourmand pour les oiseaux affamés.
J'ai peur que le plus petit des becs roses
l'emporte à travers les rangées de maïs.
Je la surveille, mais je la laisse partir.
La migration se développe également.
Vous apprenez vite la prudence.
C'était fermé.
Une bonne leçon.
Les restes de la récolte
sont une aubaine pour les oiseaux migrateurs.
Certains agriculteurs le savent
et laisser le chaume
pendant quelques semaines avant de labourer.
Mes oies ont appris à en profiter.
Ventre plein,
nous quittons la plaine d'Alsace,
direction les Vosges.
Au-dessus de la forêt,
les oies restent près de l'ULM.
L'instinct leur dit
que cet océan d'arbres sous
n'offre pas d'endroit approprié pour atterrir
ou de l'espace pour décoller en cas de danger.
Je décide de nous faire tomber
sur ce réservoir,
clos et entouré d'arbres.
Ses eaux noires fascinent les oiseaux.
Pour leur premier long vol,
mes oies ont eu
puiser dans leurs réserves.
Ils passeront la nuit à se nourrir d'algues
dans l'eau et boire.
Eau potable dont le goût
ils vont mémoriser
comme l'adresse
d'une bonne auberge à visiter encore un jour.
Auvergnat.
Nous sommes au pied du volcan du Puy Mary.
Comme à chaque nouveau paysage que nous survolons,
la conversation reprend.
C'est une bande d'oies bavardes.
Ils font entendre leur position au groupe
pour éviter un empilement en l'air.
Ils ne peuvent pas tourner la tête
à se regarder.
C'est aussi un moyen
de vérifier que tout le monde est là.
Ils reconnaissent chaque croassement individuel.
Ils s'attendent à ce que je les rejoigne
avec ces conversations aussi.
Je fais de mon mieux.
Les oies à l'avant
repéré cette tourbière attrayante
bien avant moi.
Vous pouvez appeler la migration des oies sauvages,
le tour des lacs et étangs de France.
L'eau est donc vitale pour eux.
Par terre,
Je dois admettre que c'est un site parfait.
Tous les prédateurs comme les renards ou les oiseaux de proie
serait repéré de très loin.
Quant aux autres convives,
ils semblent tout à fait inoffensifs.
Comme une oie, votre première tâche dans un nouvel endroit
est de vraiment profiter du paysage.
Après l'effort et le stress d'un vol,
rien ne vaut une bonne baignade.
L'eau est pleine de belles choses aussi.
Larves, insectes,
racines arrachées par le bas.
Je suis étonné des choses
ils peuvent faire sans jamais avoir vu
ou les a apprises de n'importe qui.
C'est inné,
entretenir 20 000 plumes,
pas seulement comme décoration,
mais une machine volante.
Fuselage, ailes, gouvernail, hélice.
Du bout de leur bec,
ils appliquent de la cire à partir d'une glande sur leur derrière,
laissant leurs plumes imperméables,
souple et résistant aux parasites.
Un défaut dans leur plumage
peut causer de l'épuisement pendant un long vol.
De vrais contorsionnistes.
Je ne pouvais pas leur apprendre ça.
je garde un œil attentif
sur le petit bec rose.
Un peu effrontée, elle s'égare
de ses frères et sœurs.
Curieux, aventureux ou insouciant ?
L'herbe est toujours plus verte, comme on dit.
Étirement du cou vers le haut,
le grand mâle n'est pas content.
L'instinct lui dit qu'un oiseau solitaire
attire les prédateurs
et met tout le monde en danger.
Elle piétine le sol.
Elle est inquiète.
Je n'interfère pas, exprès.
Finalement,
la sœur aînée au bec rose prend le contrôle,
amener le petit
retour à ses sens, retour au bercail.
Étirer et balancer le cou
c'est comme ça qu'on dit bonjour.
Rentre avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
L'incident est terminé,
mais une faille est apparue
entre les becs roses et les becs jaunes.
Nous n'avons pas besoin d'attendre longtemps
avant que le groupe ne se livre
dans une petite dispute,
oie à oie.
Les becs jaunes
prendre rapidement le dessus.
Ils sont dominants.
Les becs roses
devra faire preuve de prudence.
Chaque groupe familial a besoin d'une hiérarchie.
Cela rassure tout le monde.
Rien de tel qu'une séance de toilettage
pour réparer les liens familiaux.
Je suis toujours touché par l'attachement
mes oies ont montré depuis qu'ils étaient jeunes.
Je leur suis aussi attaché.
Pourtant je vais devoir les quitter
à la fin du voyage.
Le soir,
leurs ailes démangent.
C'est une envie irrésistible.
Il y a des jeunes,
ils doivent bouger, ils doivent voler.
A la fin d'une journée d'été,
courants chauds et froids
fouetter l'air dans la vallée.
J'en profite au maximum.
Ils devront bientôt affronter
vents violents, tempêtes, turbulences.
Alors, les enfants, vous vouliez faire de l'exercice.
La leçon de ce soir, acrobaties.
Si l'air était visible,
cette vallée serait une mer agitée
avec les vagues se brisant contre les falaises,
fouettant mes oies et ma machine.
Voici venir les rafales.
Je continue à les compter dans ma tête.
Un deux trois quatre cinq six sept.
Il en manque un.
Huit.
Le groupe est en train de se séparer.
Mes oies dérivent d'un bord à l'autre,
ci-dessus et ci-dessous.
Il ne faudrait qu'une seconde pour en perdre un.
Elle essaierait de nous trouver,
voler jusqu'à épuisement complet
et finalement nous abandonner.
Elle n'aurait aucune chance
de survie par elle-même.
C'est ma plus grande peur.
Au-dessus d'une certaine altitude,
les turbulences cessent.
L'air nous porte comme un fort courant,
calme et lisse.
Ils doivent apprendre ça pour la journée
ils doivent traverser des montagnes plus élevées, seuls.
Avec le bout de leurs longues plumes extérieures
ou plumes de vol,
chaque oiseau apprend
sentir la moindre brise
et s'y façonner.
Pas voler, mais surfer.
Plus de becs roses ou jaunes,
nous sommes une famille.
Le ciel est à nous.
Septembre.
Un épais brouillard nous retient
mis à la terre le matin.
Voler est impossible.
Il y a une peur constante
de se perdre l'un l'autre.
Les oies restent proches.
Comme d'habitude, le petit bec rose
explore seul les environs.
Dans un groupe d'oies, il y en a toujours une
plus curieux que les autres.
Cela profite souvent au groupe.
Je l'ai laissée partir,
mais gardez-la en vue.
Alors tout se passe d'un coup.
Le soleil perce le brouillard.
Le grand mâle surprend tout le monde
et anticipe mon signal de partir.
Je dois les rattraper.
Notre petit explorateur est pris au dépourvu.
Dans la nature, elle aurait une mince chance
de rejoindre le groupe.
je force l'escadron
voler près de la surface
pour rester visible pour le petit.
Au dernier moment,
elle rejoint le groupe.
Les becs roses
se rapprocher de leur petite soeur.
Cette leçon accidentelle de prudence
lui aura été utile, j'espère.
Nous quittons le lac,
la montagne et l'Auvergne.
Un nouveau jour,
un nouveau défi, la Loire.
Depuis des millénaires, les oiseaux migrateurs
ont suivi le cours des rivières.
Là, ils ont des places
pour se nourrir, se poser et se reposer.
Une route directe vers la mer.
Un parcours qui ne change jamais.
Les oiseaux de tête maintiennent
un rythme impressionnant, 30 milles à l'heure.
Les plus forts se relaient à l'avant
et consommer 20 % d'énergie en plus.
Les autres glissent dans leur sillage
et sont attirés comme les cyclistes
dans le Tour de France par le peloton de chasse.
Nous cherchons une berge.
Mais après les pluies d'automne,
la Loire gonflée
a englouti ses îles
et mangé dans ses rives.
Le grand mâle et le petit bec rose
rivaliser pour attirer l'attention et diriger le groupe.
Je remarque que nous luttons contre le vent.
Notre vitesse au sol est pratiquement nulle.
Mes oies
se fatiguent pour rien
et mon moteur commence à souffrir.
Pas d'oiseau sauvage
serait assez stupide pour continuer.
Nous devons atterrir, rapidement et en toute sécurité.
Dans ce petit aéroport tranquille,
je ne prends pas de gros risques
et être au sol
me donne une chance de vérifier le moteur
et partez quand les conditions le permettent.
Mais quitter cette petite bande d'ados
sans surveillance est une erreur.
Au final, je pense
cette petite frayeur leur sera utile.
Les aéroports offrent des prairies alléchantes
pour les oiseaux migrateurs,
mais ils doivent apprendre à être prudents,
connaître les limites.
je dois me résoudre
passer la nuit.
La sécurisation du camping reste vitale.
Les renards attaquent la nuit.
Ils s'envoleraient dans l'obscurité
et je les perdrais tous.
Le cri d'un renard les met en alerte.
Comme toutes les nuits, ils ne font que dormir
pendant quelques minutes à la fois,
avec un seul œil fermé, comme moi.
Au matin le vent est tombé,
mais les nuages sont bas.
L'ULM est trempé.
L'épaisse couverture nuageuse
nous avalerait comme des mouches.
Nous devrons attendre.
Ils s'agitent,
alors je les ai laissés se défouler.
Pas de voyage aujourd'hui, juste un survol.
La petite exploratrice et sa soeur
s'aventurer là où le courant est fort,
comme un tapis roulant sous leurs pieds.
Ils dérivent là où je ne voudrais pas qu'ils le fassent.
Au milieu de la rivière,
le piège est tendu.
canards vivants,
un pied attaché,
appeler les oiseaux qui passent et les faux canards
le faire ressembler à un endroit paisible.
Peau de chasseur.
Vide?
Chanceux.
Chasseurs inutiles.
Il faut qu'ils rentrent vite.
J'espère que cette peur va rester
dans les souvenirs de mes oies
et ils se souviendront
pour éviter des pièges similaires ailleurs.
La chasse est une de nos traditions,
mais ça tue 17 000
des 50 000 oies grises
qui assistent encore à ce voyage chaque année.
Une fenêtre météo signale notre départ.
Le plus ancien des becs roses
semble mémoriser l'emplacement
pour l'année prochaine.
Direction, plein ouest.
Les étapes se succèdent
entre ciel gris et bleu,
entre campagne et ville,
où une autre espèce rivale redoutable
vit depuis longtemps.
Homme.
Il est partout.
Mais ses activités
ne sont pas toujours nocifs pour les oiseaux sauvages.
Voici une chance pour une nouvelle leçon.
Certaines autoroutes
sont devenus des outils de navigation pour les oiseaux.
Visible de jour comme de nuit,
moins sinueuse que les rivières.
Le grand mâle et les becs roses
sont hypnotisés et ne peuvent pas détourner le regard.
Certaines espèces sont déjà habituées à ces
itinéraires faciles à suivre.
Fatigué?
Eh bien, essayez l'une des nombreuses haltes
le long du chemin.
Quelques camions de 38 tonnes,
d'accord, mais pas de chasse et pas de tracas.
Parcs éoliens
ne sont pas les meilleurs amis des oies.
Avec des vents contraires et une faible visibilité,
l'instinct des oies est de voler bas.
Surpris par ces fans géants,
ils paniquent et leur groupe se sépare.
Certains se perdent.
Je pourrais passer plus loin,
mais je préfère flirter avec le danger.
Apprivoisez leur peur.
Tous les jours,
de nouveaux moulins à vent poussent comme des champignons.
La prochaine fois, ils seront peut-être moins surpris.
Nous sommes en octobre et l'automne est à nos portes.
Jour après jour nous suivons la Loire
et ses plaines fertiles.
Leur vue super pointue
permet aux oies
distinguer toutes les nuances de vert
et de choisir
la meilleure herbe par instinct.
Ils ne se trompent jamais.
Eh bien, presque.
Mes becs roses ont dessiné le groupe
au plus délicieux
regarder une partie du cours,
le vert.
A cette époque, leur confort
autour des gens devient utile.
Je les encourage davantage.
D'autres espèces se sont déjà écrasées
parcs et jardins publics
où les gens supposent
ce sont des oiseaux décoratifs.
Ce cygne de Bewick, par exemple,
vient probablement de Sibérie
passer l'hiver ici,
où l'eau ne gèle pas.
Clairement, les trois soeurs au bec rose
s'éloignent du groupe.
La dominance des becs jaunes,
comme mon autorité paternelle,
commence à décliner.
C'est normal qu'ils se lâchent.
Au fond de moi, je sais que c'est pour le mieux.
Alors que nous nous apprêtons à partir,
un oiseau s'invite dans le groupe.
Un canard, séparé des siens
et essayer de trouver de la compagnie.
J'ai souvent vu des oiseaux solitaires
se mêlent en colonies d'espèces différentes.
Tout sauf seul
est la devise des migrateurs,
et ils sont heureux d'accueillir un oiseau
qui ne parle pas leur langue.
Aujourd'hui l'air est plein d'un nouveau parfum
ils inspirent longuement.
Je sais ce qui nous attend, mais ils ne le savent pas.
Tout à coup, ça y est,
le bleu infini de l'Atlantique,
qui doit s'éveiller en eux
des millénaires de souvenirs cachés.
Nous avons atteint une étape essentielle
sur cette grande migration.
Certains oiseaux s'arrêtent ici.
Le canard abandonné prend le commandement.
Où aller?
Elle connaît.
Elle doit reconnaître le terrain.
Tout est nouveau,
le sable, les sons,
les odeurs, la lumière,
même le goût de l'eau.
Les vagues déferlantes les intriguent.
Le grand mâle fait le guet,
prudent que jamais.
Les becs roses,
emmené par le petit explorateur,
chercher une entreprise loin de son regard.
La plage regorge de tentations,
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire.
Sans mains,
ils utilisent leur bec.
Ils grignotent chaque article,
examinant son goût, son odeur, sa texture.
Ils piétinent le sol,
espérant déloger un morceau savoureux.
Les oiseaux meurent par milliers
d'avoir accidentellement ingéré
les tonnes de déchets jetés sur les plages
ou renvoyé par la mer.
Ils ont grandi maintenant.
Je ne serai pas éternellement avec eux.
Ils doivent apprendre par eux-mêmes
la différence entre ce qui va bien
et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Le grand mâle entend le canard
mais ne peut pas la voir.
Est-elle perdue ?
On dirait qu'ils ne peuvent rien faire
pour la sauver maintenant.
Comment a-t-elle pu résister à un tel mâle,
avec cette tenue bicolore ?
Elle montre sa prise une dernière fois.
Nous ne la reverrons plus.
Un jour mes oies
devra également trouver un partenaire.
Un qu'ils garderont à vie.
La marée monte, le soleil se couche.
Il est maintenant temps de se percher.
Ce grand vol,
commun aux oiseaux migrateurs du monde entier,
les prend du rivage
dans les marais intérieurs pour passer la nuit.
Puis revenez le matin.
Ce va et vient
est une leçon vitale pour mes oies,
qui passeront de longs mois ici.
Nous sommes un peu en avance,
mais quelques grues ont déjà commencé
arrivant d'Europe du Nord.
Les oies sauvages
arrivera dans les prochains jours.
Il reste une dernière leçon à retenir.
Le plus difficile, le moins certain.
Le temps est venu
pour rendre la liberté à mes oies.
Dans cette réserve naturelle sans chasse,
ils ont toutes les chances.
Mais ils devront m'oublier.
Les becs jaunes sont déjà lointains,
les becs roses, toujours aussi affectueux.
Mais je dois les quitter maintenant.
Se précipiter avec eux une dernière fois.
je les imagine
rejoindre les oies sauvages pour s'arrêter ici.
L'école de la migration
les y a préparés,
non seulement pour apprendre des autres oies,
mais aussi pour transmettre
ce que nous avons découvert ensemble.
Je les imagine traversant les montagnes
pour rejoindre leurs pâturages d'hiver.
Et, je les vois,
un jour, enseignant à leurs propres jeunes
les voies de migration.